okay let's talk now about the size of
Donald Trump's much touted jobs numbers
they're actually not that good so we're
gonna dig into the numbers today now
remember we've been doing these economic
analyses lately remember Donald Trump
claimed that his stock market numbers
are the best and last week we looked and
it turns out that over their first three
years Barack Obama's numbers for the
stock market growth were significantly
better than Donald Trump's stock market
growth during his first three years we
looked at debt and deficit remember that
Barack Obama saw slower deficit growth
and even in some years there was
year-over-year deficit reduction
straight up while Donald Trump has
overseen some of the biggest deficit
increases in a long time and then we get
to Donald Trump's claims about jobs it
turns out that during Donald Trump's
first three years job growth slowed down
to where Barack Obama left off at the
end of his presidency now all the normal
caveats here there is no one number that
tells you everything you need to know
about how the economy is doing that
applies to all of this stuff stock
market unemployment rate job creation
whatever but when you compare the
numbers you see that Barack Obama during
his last three years in office created
8.1 million jobs and Donald Trump during
the three years that followed created
6.6 million jobs this is a greater than
18 percent reduction in job growth under
Donald Trump / the numbers from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics to put it a
different way if we want to think about
it monthly under the Trump economy we
are gaining a hundred and eighty-two
thousand jobs per month on average and
during Barack Obama's last three years
where he handed the economy over to
Donald Trump the economy gained two
hundred and twenty four thousand to
twenty four under Obama 182 under Trump
now there are two things to understand
here one of those is estimates versus
revisions the first Friday of each month
we unless it's the first of the month in
which case it might be the second Friday
we get job create
estimates from the previous month and
those make headlines but later those
numbers are fine-tuned or adjusted and
they are finalized we get the final
actual numbers and under Donald Trump
often the estimates are higher than the
actual numbers we eventually get now if
you present these numbers to Trump or to
his acolytes they'll say well Trump's
creating higher quality jobs or wages
are higher or up under Donald Trump's
job creation or whatever those are
different arguments and we can research
those numbers if those are the goal
posts that they want to move to but they
have been talking about job creation and
the bottom line is that job creation
slowed about 20% under Donald Trump this
is a sort of rinse repeat and go back to
the beginning with the lies they brag
about stocks we look at the numbers well
the first three years under Obama were
stronger than the first three years
under Trump
oh well then they come up with some
reason Obama was in the middle of a
recovery and it's expected that you
would have bigger stock market growth
whatever but then later they say Obama's
recovery was actually terrible well I
thought you cited it as the reason why
the numbers were better than Trump's
numbers
it's just sir it's a circle it's a
never-ending circle so then they brag
about jobs but then we look and well
actually job growth slowed when Donald
Trump took over so then they switch and
they'll brag about growth as they
recently have been GDP growth but
remember that Donald Trump promised four
to six percent GDP growth and we
actually got 2.9 in 2019 it's an endless
cycle it's not really about arguing with
them about the numbers and as we've been
talking about there's really no point in
arguing with trumpets about the numbers
it doesn't matter they're going to
rationalize whatever it is that they
believe to be true or what you can
convince them is true they're still
going to rationalize it away we're not
gonna win this 20/20 election by
convincing trumpets that the economic
numbers are different than the ones that
they have been told or that they believe
are true but the point is to understand
that because it's this endless loop we
just need to ignore the trumpets they're
going to do their thing
Trump's going to
his rallies and he's gonna lie and
they're gonna be fired up and cheer and
believe everything he says we need to
activate the people that already know
Trump's a disaster but may not be
planning to vote just nine months from
now let's take a quick break make sure
you're following me on instagram at
david pakman and while you're there
follow the show on instagram as well at
david pakman show we'll take a quick
break
radio host Tom Hartman joins me next to
talk about his great new book as many of
you know I am super careful about where
we publish and distribute david pakman
show content it's a really important
decision that we make where do we want
our content to be we don't want to
spread ourselves too thin but we want to
make sure that we're taking advantage of
good platforms where our content could
do well and over the last couple of
months I've been testing publishing our
content to a platform called library
that's lbr why I've mentioned it once or
twice before and we are absolutely
loving it it's a fantastic platform
where our revenue as publishers does not
depend on some algorithm deciding
whether an ad should run before a video
or not in fact it's actually an ad free
platform where our revenue is determined
by the number of people that watch our
videos and also by the tips that are
left for us in credits that are in
platform credits it's their own sort of
currency so to speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified signup we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit will get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest
that they're running who ever can refer
the most new users gets a huge reward
which would be a big big boost to us so
check it out link down in the video
description sign up let me know what you
think